one of the most common questions I get
asked is Patrick how do you find time to
read books with your family kids see you
over business travel show all this stuff
you know how do you find time to read so
today I decided to have some fun with
this today we're going to talk about
eight different ways you can find time
to read number one every day take a
20-minute break I've been doing this for
as long as I can remember I go grab a
book off the shelf go grab the bathroom
keys head to the bathroom get set up
close the door and I am doing nothing
but reading books I love doing this
because no one ever interrupts me in the
middle of the day saying you have an
appointment here I get a chance to read
for 20 minutes number two instead of
taking a shower take a bath this allows
you to pour yourself a glass of wine
relax and read a book and enjoy yourself
number three always go to bed with books
next to you it should be the first thing
you do when you wake up and the last
thing you do before you go to sleep and
the great thing about reading books in
bed they never leave you when you wake
up
number four always have books downloaded
on your mobile device this gives you the
opportunity to have a book with you no
matter where you are number five always
walk and read whether you're walking
your dogs or walking with your
sweetheart it gives you another chance
to read a book number six always have a
headset with you so you can listen to
audiobooks my recommendation is to
listen to biographies on audiobooks and
everything else on regular books number
seven always read while exercising I
can't think of how many books are
finished just in the gym alone
number eight turn off all the
notifications on your phone each
notification can distract you from
reading your book using these eight
simple ways is the reason why I've wrote
over a thousand books in my life and I
don't see any reason why if you apply
some of these things why you can't
finish a minimum of a book a week and
possibly when they become officially
addicted to reading and by the way if
somebody tells you I don't have any time
to read can you please share this
video with them and maybe tag their name
on the bottom thanks for watching
I'm Patrick but if you host a value tame
and I just want to thank you for all the
love we get regularly on social media
and also for my top 100 books for
entrepreneurs click on the link to go to
my website you'll see a link right there
for top 100 books if you haven't
subscribed to the channel as well be
sure to do so on the bottom and stay
tuned for the next episode